Mother Earth: Our end was imminent
yet finality relented.
Wind, water and fire gently revived;
you and I reconciled,
rhythms realigned,
the blues gone green.
Your care in conserving
in exchange for my fruit
and replenishing this picturous
restoring of painted skies,
mountains rolling,
forest covering --
no more warming.
The purity and simplicity
of how we used to be.
You remember me?
All I give to humanity?
Housing, land, seas, birds,
beast and all of mankind,
exclusively the interface
where you and the elements meet
and vibrate harmoniously.
(Piano plays)
(Violin plays)
(Music)
(Music tempo quickens)
(Violin plays)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
My beauty altered,
muddied waters, fields stripped bare,
interior scarred beyond repair,
our memories eroding.
You once obsessed over my frame
and how I came to be;
my nature, its polarity --
how my sweet winds whisper softly,
yet assault seas.
You remember me?
All I give to humanity?
Housing, land, seas, birds,
beast and all of mankind --
exclusively the interface
where you and the elements meet
and vibrate harmoniously.
The unseen traveler forever passing,
carrying life,
moving,
awning of earth felt and heard,
strong and stirring,
blowing.
Breathe you in, cleansing wind,
gentle and still,
quieter.
The source eternally here,
ascent and descending:
air.
Rhythmic flow,
fluid and graceful,
waves of serenity,
smooth strings of purity,
rains replenishing rapidly,
rivers of dreams,
raging springs
covering earth in abundance,
universal solvent dissolving,
drink, liquid, life and power:
water.
Born when the universe was formed,
warmed mankind,
gave him light,
colored rays illuminate ember flickers
incandescent, powerful and brilliant.
Sacred son of air, father of fury,
heat dancing vigorously
between perfection and beauty.
Unconfined agility,
fast and fancy,
sparks of ingenuity rise:
fire.
(Canku One Star dances)
(Choir chants)
(Drums)
(Drumming and chanting)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Violin plays)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)